got some breaking news to bring you now
and the Prime Minister Rishi sunak has
just tweeted about the situation in
Sudan he has said UK armed forces have
completed a complex and Rapid evacuation
of British diplomats and their families
from Sudan and made a significant
escalation in violence and threats to
Embassy staff he goes on to say I pay
tribute to the commitment of our
diplomats and bravery of the military
personnel who carried out this difficult
operation we're continuing to pursue
every Avenue to end the Bloodshed in
Sudan and ensure the safety of British
Nationals remaining in the country
adding I urge the parties to lay down
their arms and Implement an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire to ensure
civilians can leave conflict zones so
that's from the Prime Minister just
there and the foreign secretary James
cleverley also tweeting today too saying
um due to escalating threats against
foreign diplomats the UK has evacuated
Embassy staff from Sudan our top
priority he says Remains the safety of
British Nationals
we are working around the clock to
broker international support to end the
Bloodshed in Sudan so James cleverly
tweeting that and then the prime
minister in the last few minutes on that
escalating violence in Sudan we can
speak now live to our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes where Lots
happened in the last few minutes Deborah
yes we've just had this confirmation
that we'd really been waiting for we
knew from yesterday that the UK was
planning to evacuate its diplomats from
Sudan it's obviously a high risk
operation it's an active conflict Zone
the French said this morning that they
were evacuating evacuating their staff
alongside other partners and obviously
we assume that the British were one of
those partners and just now the Prime
Minister confirming that that is the
case the UK military the UK Armed Forces
went into Sudan and they evacuated not
just the British diplomats their
dependents as well of course
um and have left um the embassy
temporarily closing
um it would seem and the effort as the
foreign secretary said in his message in
his tweet
um is to work from outside the country
now of course on pressuring these two
warring generals that have triggered
huge violence over the last nine days to
cease fighting but it's going to leave
British Nationals that are still in
Sudan and haven't been rescued if he
didn't have a diplomatic passport you
weren't getting on one of these flights
um feeling very abandoned uh the the you
know the UK will say that they're well
of course their diplomats on the ground
weren't able to perform their functions
um of course given the threat to life
and that actually by evacuating them
maybe counter-intuitively it means that
they'll be able to do more to help the
British Nationals still in the country
it's such a difficult situation not just
for the UK but for all countries that
have missions in Sudan they need to help
their own Nationals but clearly they
have to be mindful of the risk to their
Embassy staff and the decision for the
UK and others has been to remove those
staff and then to work from outside the
country to coordinate efforts to help
foreign Nationals including British
Nationals who are still under Fire and
still in Terror
and I suppose Deborah the biggest
problem that the military will face is
that the ceasefires that have been in
place haven't worked
no and actually it because there's been
a relative Lull in the fighting over the
last couple of days uh because of this
attempt to De ceasefire that was called
that the um the UK France the Us and
other nations have moved in to evacuate
their people but even with the temporary
lull there has been violations of that
there were air strikes today it's not by
any sense uh a safe situation there were
reports earlier as well of of one of the
French convoys coming under Fire during
the evacuation and so if this is what a
lull looks like you can only imagine
what it looks like with full-scale
fighting which is clearly what will
continue unless a more lasting ceasefire
can be agreed and like the foreign
secretary has said that is the UK's
priority if they aren't able people to
stop fighting though then it creates an
enormous problem an even bigger problem
for the UK and others because British
Nationals are still stuck in Khartoum
and they are wondering what their
Embassy is going to be doing for them
the embassy now is temporarily closed
and so they're going to probably be
feeling quite abandoned you'd imagine
um but the the UK is in a really really
difficult situation because as they've
said it hasn't been possible for their
Embassy staff to operate as a
functioning diplomatic mission in these
current circumstances and they seem to
believe that they'll be able to do a
better job from outside the country it's
worth noting actually that the
Ambassador uh was not was not in cartoon
hasn't been in the country since this
fighting started
um but you can only imagine that he's
been advice amazing on this whole crisis
from London Deborah we um we have a
Tweet now from the ministry of Defense
um and they have stated this obviously
from the defense secretary Ben Wallace
saying um the UK Armed Forces undertook
a military operation with the United
States France and other allies they have
evacuated British Embassy staff and
their dependents from khotun due to the
escalating threats against diplomats now
the operation involved more than 1 200
Personnel from 16 Air Assault Brigade
The Royal Marines and the RAF and he's
saying I'm grateful to all of our
partners so this was a Deborah a huge
operation here
yeah so I'm sure we'll get details as to
exactly what was used to extract the um
the British diplomats uh in the in the
next few hours it's been a mission that
the the mod has been planning for a
number of days now the request to go in
the decision to go in uh wasn't taken
until later but the military as always
has this tendency to plan for lots of
eventualities and clearly you can well
imagine
um people inside the permanent joint
headquarters looking at the situation
unraveling in Sudan and wondering
whether they might be called upon by the
foreign office to go in and extract
British diplomats so they have been
working on this Sudan is a vast
okay I think we may have lost Deborah
Haynes there but um just to um just
bring you up to date what's been
happening in the last few minutes we've
had a a tweet a statement from the Prime
Minister uh confirming that a complex uh
rapid evacuation of British diplomats
and their families
um had taken place in Sudan and this of
course amid significant escalation of
violence and threats to Embassy staff
and the the violence that we've seen in
the last two weeks in Sudan James
cleverley also confirming uh that that
had happened and adding that the duty
was to British Nationals and making sure
they were safely taken from the country
um and and then hearing from the
ministry of defense and Ben Wallace
confirming a few more details really of
that operation saying that it actually
involved 1 200 Personnel from the 16 air
so Brigade The Royal Marines and the RAF
working in conjunction conjunction with
the United States and France